Donald Trump's daughter.
Ivanka Trump not only made a fool out of herself
holding a can of Goya beans, but appears to
have broken the same ethics rules and federal
law that Kellyanne Conway broke when she previously
promoted Vanka Trump's jewelry line.
And now Donald Trump is also getting in on
the action.
So let me back up a little bit and explain
the entire thing to you now.
Goya Foods, commonly just known as Goya, is
an American company that sells food products
that are often in the Hispanic foods aisle
in grocery stores.
It's kind of a weird name, but not really
the focus of this segment.
But it's everything from beans to frozen products,
flour, coconut, canned coconut sauces, marinades,
et cetera, that Goya sells a lot of different
things.
And the company is owned by the non-user family,
and they're the second of richest Spanish
American family owned by Spanish.
Now I'm talking about the country of Spain.
Are a billionaire family from from Spain?
The CEO, Robert Lunana, was recently invited
to the White House to one of these propaganda
events that Donald Trump has been holding.
And the GooYa CEO said that Donald Trump is
a blessing for the United States, that the
United States is blessed to have Donald Trump
as president.
And many people, including many Hispanic customers
of Goya products, didn't like it.
And there were calls for boycotts.
The normal reaction outrage cycle took place.
Oh, everybody calling for a boycott is suppressing
the speech of Goya.
Well, this Tuesday, Ivana Trump tweeted a
picture of herself holding a can of Goya black
beans with the message, If it's Goya, it has
to be good, followed by a Spanish translation.
C.S.
Goya, the anarchist, said Bueno.
Or as Argentinians would say, C.S.
Gosha, the annica said Bueno.
So this was just wacky.
She looks like a crazy person.
The optics are bizarre.
And I tweeted it out with the message, Something
is very wrong with this woman.
But then it started to get more interesting.
Yesterday, Donald Trump did something similar,
posing with Goya products in the White House,
including what looked like a can of coconut
chocolate wafers, beans and more.
And this is a violation of federal law.
Five CFR twenty six thirty five dot seven
oh two.
That's a mouthful.
It's called use of public office for private
gain.
And it says an employee shall not use his
public office for his own private gain, for
the endorsement of any product, service or
enterprise, or for the private gain of friends,
relatives or persons with whom the employee
is affiliated in a none, got none, none non-governmental
capacity.
This is the exact same thing that Kellyanne
Conway violated when she suggested people
go out and buy Yvonne because jewelry.
In short, people in public office can't endorse
products in this way.
But that gets us to the next level of insanity,
which is on the one hand, if Enke as an adviser
to Donald Trump, on the other hand, she's
not supposed to work for Trump because of
anti nepotism laws.
But on the other hand, they've gotten around
this by making her this kind of vague adviser
rather than somebody with a formal position,
which she clearly would be barred from having.
But she's still an administration official
of sorts, but she's breaking the law by promoting
products.
But they can go back to well, she's really
an unofficial adviser.
It's a circle of swamp.
It's a never ending swamp that gets deeper
and deeper with every passing week of this
administration.
But here's the deal.
I actually have an optimistic message for
you today.
I'm not worried about this.
I'm not.
The administration doesn't care.
Trump's family doesn't care.
This is the swamp filling corruption.
We were told they were going to end.
We just have to remove them in three and a
half months.
Keep an eye on the bigger picture rather than
getting bogged down in individual instances
of swamp filling.
We know they have to go if Vanka posing with
black beans doesn't change anything.
Yes, of course it's illegal.
They're not going to be any consequences.
Just vote them out.
Just vote.
We have all the information we need and we
are prepared to vote him out in November.
But are we going to get enough turnout to
do it?
I hope we don't all have that horrible feeling
again on November 4th that we had in November
of 2016.
I don't want it and I'll be doing everything
I can to prevent it.
But, you know, don't try.
Try not to worry too much about yet another
lawbreaking action.
We've just got to remove them.
Otherwise, this will continue.